hey what's up guys it's Marcus Brownlee
here from mkbhd and today I'm going to
be giving you my thoughts and opinions
as well as a technical preview of the
upcoming dual screen laptop PC Bhaiji
screen called the space book
so desktop dual screen and dual monitor
setups have become more and more popular
in the 21st century as I do offer
massive amounts of screen real estate
and make a workspace easier and more
productive to work with plus they do
have the cool factor a lot of people
like well satisfy all you people out
there who are as leaky as me and do like
the dual screen setup a company based in
Alaska called G screen is ready to
release a dual screen laptop which would
be the first ever of its kind and has
gotten really good press coverage and a
lot of hype in the past couple of weeks
so I just wanted to give you guys a
brief rundown and my overview of it
so here it is guys this is the really
nice picture that G screen Corp com
their company website has featured on
their website and it lives look
extremely nice now you'll notice a
couple of things about this preliminary
picture first of all the fact that there
are two monitors built into one laptop
is a first the second thing is that
those are actually supposed to be 15.4
inch individual displays so they're
actually debating between a 15 16 or 17
inch inch initial G screen space book
and you guys can help them decide which
model they first release by following
them on Twitter becoming a fan on
Facebook and all sorts of other things
which I'll include in the description of
this video so if we scroll down a bit on
the G screen comm space book home page
you'll be able to view of the specs of
the G screen space book that are there
are thinking of releasing so we'll start
from the top they are thinking that the
15.4 inch space book would weigh around
eight point seven pounds and thus
Facebook planned at launch would be a 16
inch and /or like I mentioned before a
17 inch space book you can choose
between Windows 7 Windows Vista or
Windows XP which is expected and you can
choose between an Intel Core 2 Duo 3.5 3
gigahertz or an extremely powerful 2.8
gigahertz processor I'm running an Intel
Core 2 quad and I have to say I really
do like the Intel line of processors
next on the list is the graphics card
and chipset and you can see here the
NVIDIA GeForce 9800 GT with a half of
gig of ram that they're expecting to
release it with is a very powerful
graphics card and I'm excited for a
laptop
with a nice graphics card like this with
two monitors and see how the graphics
card holds up under the conditions that
dual monitors would present for such a
card
now another one of the most important
things to consider when purchasing a
laptop is the hard drive size and this
one will come with an either 250 gig or
500 gig SATA hard drive which is quite
nice next on the list is communication
and I actually have 802 11 B G and N
wireless on my laptop and I've been
extremely satisfied with it and this
laptop is set to have an 802 11 n
connection as well the next thing on the
list is a 6 in-1 media card reader you
may have heard of media card readers you
might actually have one on your laptop
and this one will read SD MMC and a
number of other popular memory cards
this next list here might look very
standard but if we scroll down it I'm
just going to give you an overview of
what I find the most impressive first
there's an one DC in Jack one headphone
out and one mic jack that's also very
standard one land with metal shielding a
modem connector 3 USB ports which is
decent and that'll also be that
multimedia card reader and last but
definitely not least an HDMI slot and
this will be really nice if you want to
hook up a third monitor to your dual
screen laptop I really would love to be
able to do something like that have a
HDMI monitor connected to my dual screen
laptop that would just be an awesome
looking setup it's set to be released in
quarter of 4 of 2009 which is around
December right now and it's actually
going to have a nine cell battery which
is actually a decent sized battery with
the 17 inch HP laptop I'm running right
now with a 9 cell battery I can get
around 2 hours of battery life however
with a graphics card that heavy and with
two screens on the laptop I'm guessing
it's going to run around an hour and a
half maximum for something like this on
windows 7 so if you guys want to check
all of this out you guys can visit the G
screen Corp comm home page and also
check out their blog where they post
some nice things about the specs and the
the coverage they've been getting for
press and it's been really nice to read
about the history and the development of
the G screen space book and as well as
all that the press they've gotten in the
past couple of weeks so again I will
have all the
links to this in the description their
blog their main website their Twitter
and their Facebook pages as well as some
neat pictures and things that I found to
show you guys at the end of this video
so if you guys want to check out those
pictures and everything else gets check
in the description and it would be
really awesome if I could get a review
unit from G screen that would be
absolutely awesome and I would
definitely do a number of videos about
the hardware the software and the
integration with the dual monitors so
this has been mkbhd and thank you for
watching this little overview video of
the G screens Facebook and I'll talk to
you guys in the next video
you